[Music]
aloha reject nation how you doing look
who I got back with me Andrew Gordon
from the movie source channel Aloha one
of my really close friends is here with
me today I just introduced him to Aldo
Jones his weird trailer for infinity of
war just showed it to him but today
we're gonna watch cliff he put together
I think Tony Stark kills Thanos
exclusive leaked scene from the Avengers
infinity war spoiler alert guys spoilers
all the way and hey patron today
shoutout gonna go out to totally jumbled
the into your timeline you he only ever
had to wipe out half the universe if he
gets all the Infinity stones
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man yeah that was epic I appreciate
it all though for for doing that in
terms of teasing his upcoming trailer
because it could have easily just done
like a snippet of that and they would be
like alright cool but that's a funny ass
joke right there it would be so much
easier for the Avengers to defeat Thanos
if they just had a Death Note on them
the entire time man obviously add the
writers Markus and McFeely for Avengers
affair where they clearly been hitting
this thing in it we made it out there
Jones by that but I actually thought for
a second when we saw the plaque book I
thought it was going to be Tom Riddle's
diary I thought that was a previous
Terry :
I think the next step for Aldo Jones to
transition from weird trailers is to do
weird movies ya know I'd be down like
why does every single movie have to be
so straightforward and serious right
yeah especially powerful no humor
totally jumbles got to give you a shout
out buddy totally jumbled lives in some
state that's like boring and far away he
is married he just had a kid named
Skyland graduations he's gonna it's a
she's a girl and she's gonna grow up to
be one hot piece of ass I can't wait for
his daughter to turn 18 I keep telling
him that TJ I'm letting you know right
now you gonna pimp her out dude pimp her
out if I was to be a dad
I would totally raise my little girl to
be a [ __ ] little girl I'm advising you
to do the same exact thing
TJ clearly this guy is Godfather
material I'm godfather material right
here bring back a side of me for this
think it's funny to just talk to people
the Newports just like a really creepy
level it makes me laugh and it grosses
everyone else out I'm glad you're part
of the reject nation I'm happy to have
you as a patronage act it makes him
laugh and that's all that counts
I'll get comments at people calling me
weird and creepy but as long as you're
laughing TJ that's all that counts to me
what is life without humor the DC
Universe guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell so it means something aldo jones
thanks a lot buddy most importantly
check out Andrew Gordon on the movie
source channel people and happy to have
you here for this snippet of a video